you're going to have all these different
cast and characters within running but
we all serve a different purpose my
purpose is really just to show one
anyone can run two black indigenous
people of color have every right to be
in running spaces just as much as
anybody else does three that there is
such a powerful spiritual component
within running and that it is actually a
great tool for mental health and for you
to reclaim your sense of mental Clarity
and lastly it just feels good and it is
such a great tool for tuning the temple
it's karma yoga for your body it really
is just like you do Karma Yoga when
you're cleaning your house it is just
the same way you're doing it for your
body